ام
اهلا بكم
لجنه انديه الدوري المصري لكره القدم يوم
الثلاثاء روابط الالتراس لمشجعي كره القدم
باعتبارها جماعات ارهابيه مسلحه وبرر
المسؤولون الخطوه بانها تاتي بعد تواصل
اعمال العنف من جانب بعض منتسبيها به
الروابط نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين ما دلالات اقدام رابطه انديه
الدوري المصري على اصدار تصنيف بهذه
الخطوره على مجموعه من المواطنين
وما وجاهه التحذيرات من امكانيه ان تؤسس
هذه الخطوه مفوض تصنيفات تهدد امن وسلامه
المجتمع المصري
فى سابقه هى الاولى من نوعها اعتبر مسؤول
انديه الدوري المصري لكره القدم روابط
الالتراس جماعات ارهابيه مسلحه
وتمنع من دخول المباريات وتقابل بالمقاطعه
من كافه وسائل الاعلام التي تتعاطى مع
اخبارها ولان اللجنه الامنيه ليست جهه
اختصاص في ما يلي اصدار مثل هذه الاحكام
فان مراقبين اعتبروا ما صدر منها تماهيا
مع نزعه التجريم التي باتت اداه حاسمه او
حسم فاعله ضد كل من يرفض تماهى مع ما
تقرره السلطه
جماعه ارهابيه مسلحه
قد يعتقد البعض للوهله الاولى ان المقصود
هو جماعه الاخوان المسلمين للمره الثانيه
لكن قد تتعجب من ان المقصود هي جماعات
رياضيه هي روابط اولتراس التي نشات عام
الفين وسبعه كغيرها من روابط التشريع
الموجوده في كل انحاء العالم كما ازداد
العشب عندما تعلم ان الحكم صادر من مستشار
قانوني سابق بالرغم ان القاعده القانونيه
هي خصوصيه العقوبه وليس عموميتها انه قرار
لجنه الانديه المصريه برئاسه المستشار
مرتضى منصور المرشح الرئاسي السابق
والرئيس الحالي لنادي الزمالك هذا الكلام
يتناقض مع تصريحات اخرى لوزير الرياضه
الذي اكد تعاون وزارته مع هؤلاء الشباب ل
تنظيم دورات هم و شكوى هؤلاء من عدم وجود
مؤسسات تستوعب هم ما المشكله اذن البعض
يرى انها شخصيه لخلاف ال ال تراس مع مرتضى
منصور بسبب النقص بوعوده لعدم السماح
لهؤلاء بحضور مباريات فيما يرى البعض
الاخر انها سياسيه بسبب رفض ال ال ترسل
ممارسات الداخليه بل ومشاركتهم في ثوره
الخامس والعشرين من يناير ثم مشاركه بعض
هذه الروابط في مظاهرات رافضى الانقلاب
هذه اصوات اطلاق نار ليس لمواجهه مظاهره
للاخوان وانما لتفريق المظاهره الاخيره
لرغبه الاولتراس فى دوران شبرا التي
نظموها احتجاجا على اعتقال الامن لعدد
منهم القرار الاخير للجنه الانديه يستبق
الحكم القضائي في القضيه التي رفعها منصور
وبالتالي يبقى السؤال ماذا لو صدر القرار
القضائي بعدم اعتبار الجماعه ارهابيه
ثم ها ال اصبح وصف مؤسسه بالارهاب
والوسيله الاسهل للتخلص من المعارضه حتى
وان كانت رياضيه كيف سيتم تطبيق الامر على
هؤلاء الذين لم يفصحوا عن افعالهم حتى هذه
اللحظه وكيف يتم التمييز بين الالتراس و
غيرهم و
موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور عصام عبد الشافي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه اهلا بك وايضا ينضم الينا
من واشنطن الدكتور نبيل ميخائيل استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج واشنطن
نرحب بضيفنا من واشنطن ولكن قبل بدايه
النقاش مع ضيفينا نحاول الوقوف على اه
جانب من رؤيه روابط الالتراس مع ضيفنا
عماد هاشم عضو الالتراس والذي نرحب وعبر
الهاتف من القاهره اهلا بك خدمات
اه ما هو تفسيركم الدوافع التي تقف وراء
صدور هذا التصنيف يحقق
على اي حاجه في ال في البلد يعني ان كان
الوحيده اللي دي الوقتي في ال في مصر
قادره على كل المؤسسات الدوله الدوله
عليها مش حياتها
المؤسسه الوحيده اللي نفسها ال اه الحاجه
الوحيده
القرارات المصري العربيه
يعني كيف
سيكون ردكم على هذا التصنيف
الداخليه في الحكومه احنا علينا احنا كل
يوم كل يوم بيقولوا عندنا عندنا
طيب اه يعني اه
كل يوم
يعني هل
هو يعني
يعني
اه شكرا جزيلا لك
اتحول الى واشنطن الدكتور نبيل يعني
الدكتور ما دخل اصلا ما داخل لجنه انديه
كره القدم باصدار تصنيفات بهذه الخطوره
بحيث توصف بانها ارهابيه هكذا بكل سهوله
اه طبعا يعني ال المنظمات او الهيئه
الرياضيه بتحاول تراقب السلوك المشجعين اه
وفي الحقيقه يعني عاوزه اقول اربع نقاط
وبعدين يعني اعمل نوع من ال اه الاستنتاج
اه يعني في العلوم الاجتماعيه بعض الخبراء
والعلماء زي مثلا اذ ذاك بيقول ان ظاهره
العنف الرياضي
بدل ما اوروبا كانت تحارب نفسها والدول ما
بينهم وما بين بعض وبايرن ميونيخ لا عاما
مع مانشستر يونايتد يبقى احسن المشجعين
انت بردو يبقى احسن ما هي حرب
اتجاه في العلوم الاجتماعيه والانسانيه ان
العنف الرياضي بيمنع العنف في مجالات اخرى
في المجتمع
كانت من يبقى فيه عنف في مباراه كره يعني
المعلق المشهور محمد لطيف كانت اللطيف كان
ينتقد ظاهره اه حرق الجرائد في اخر الوقت
في الوقت الضائع مثلا يقول احنا اتعلمنا
الموضوع لا فيها
فيها والمصريين اخذوا العادي فكان كان فيه
ظاهره الجرائد وحرب العراق في نهايه
المباراه واستمرت لفتره طويله الامر
الثالث
غريبه يعني ماكنش فيه يعني كنت بكره بس
مثلا كانت المناقشات الرياضيه زمان الاهلي
احسن واحسن ولا حسن شحاته الخطيب احسن ولا
فاروق ماكناش يعني بهذه الدرجه من العنف
والحماس انا حاولت
ولوقت معملين يهتفوا بطريقه عنيفه جدا
اللي محمد ابو تريكه
ال الظاهره غريبه
في المبارات الدوليه
الزائد
يعني موضوعنا هو هذا السؤال
دكتور عصام عبد الشافي يعني هذا هذا قرار
يعني خطير ان تصنف الجماعه ما بانها
ارهابيه وهي من روابط الالتراس لكره القدم
هل تملك برايك لجنه لجنه لكره القدم حق
تصنيف جماعه
بالتوصيف مثل هذا لا تملك اي لجنه فنيه او
رياضيه اطلاق تصنيفات عشوائيه على اي
تغيير التيارات او على اي جماعه من
الجماعات هذا ابتداء ثانيا الحديث عند مثل
هذا القرار يتطلب الوقوف على عده اعتبرها
التوقيت توقيت القرار الهدف من هذا القرار
المستفيد من هذا القرار التاثيرات التي
يمكن ان تنطبق على مثل هذا القرار في
العلوم السياسيه يتم التعامل معها على
انها شكل من اشكال جماعات الضغط ينشا
بالاساس للتعبير عن رغبات معينه لا يسهل
ممارسه العمل السياسي لا يسعى للتاثير في
صنع القرار السياسي ولكنه يرى يعبر عن
رغبات ومطالب فئه معينه قطاع معين ايا
كانت طبيعه اهتماماتهم لربط الارض كمان
كما اشار المهتمون والمحللون ال مثل هذا
الجانب نشات بالاساس في الخمسينيات من
القرن العشرين في معظم دول العالم لها
فروع في كل دول العالم بدات تنتشر في مصر
في ال في الالفيه الاولى يعني الفين وخمسه
الفين وسته بدات مع بشده التنظيم وقدرتها
على الحج قدرتها على التعبئه بدات
المواجهه الامنيه
ودائما كما في مصر كما في غيرها من النظم
الاستبداديه والتسلطيه الاله الامنيه
مقدمه في التعامل مع كل التيارات
والجماعات ايا كانت انتماءاتها طبيعه نظام
سياسي كانت البدايه سنه الفين وتسعه مع
احداث استاد اسيوط كانت قمه الماسي التي
تعرض لها جماعات الالتراس فى احداث
بورسعيد في الواحد في الاول من فبراير
2012 في هذه المقدرات سقط اكثر من سبعين
شهيدا مصريا من مشجعي مباريات كره القدم
واكثر من الف جريح كل وسائل الاعلام
المصريه الصادره في هذا التوقيت تناولت مع
الحدث على ان من يقف خلفه ومصطفى قيادات
الصف الاول والصف الثاني من وزاره
الداخليه وعدد من رموز الحزب الوطنى فى
محافظه بورسعيد وعدد من رجال الاعمال
الضالعين في محافظه بور صحيح وبالتالي
الاسوا من هذا الامر عندما تولى الدكتور
محمد مرسى وكانت الذكرى السنويه الثانيه
لثوره فبراير وكانت الذكرى السنويه ل
احداث مجزره بورسعيد سقط ايضا عدد من
القتلى في ماده انسانيه في بور سعيد وتم
تحميل الامر اعاده تصنيف الامر بشكل مخالف
لاعتبارات سياسيه وصدرت احكام تم اعتبارها
قضاء اعتبارات قضايا سياسيه بالاساس ضد
عدد لم يكن هم المتورطين في القيام بمثل
هذه الحاله وخرج من ها ال متورطون السيد
الاشكاليه الكبرى استاذنا ان من يقف خلف
هذا الحادث خلف مثل هذا القرار الان
مجموعه من رؤساء الانديه في الدور المصري
ومجموعه من الاعلاميين المصريه
مجموعه رؤساء الانديه في الفهم بالاساس
احد ادوات انه ال الادوات التي اعتمد
عليها النظام السياسي القائم منذ الانقلاب
العسكري اللي تمرير عدد من سياسته في كافه
القطاعات هذا ابتداء عدد كبير من
الاعلاميين المصريين
الف الفكره نحن امام اه احد رؤساء الانديه
دون ذكر اسمه لاننا اعتقد ان ذكر اسمي
يمكن ان يعطيها قيمه لا يستحقها احد رؤساء
الانديه يمارس يوميا ما يمكن وصفه
بالارهاب الفكري واللفظي والغاز الدول
معنوي في حق كل المعارضين حتى السياسيين
بغض النظر عن انه له دورا سياسيا او غير
ليس له دور السياسي ولكن تعرض للحادث
المؤخر هذه تم توصيف هذا الحادث على انه
اعتداء اعتقد انه بالاساس كان مجرد فزاعه
السياسيه كوسيله اوقف مقدمه اساسيه
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الجماعات ومثل هذه
التيارات بالاساس نحن في دوله ما يجب
علينا في زمن المعايير المحتله في ظل غياب
القيم الاخلاقيه والمبادئ التي يمكن
الاستناد اليه في ظل غياب القانون الذي
يحكم في ظل منظومه نظام انقلاب عسكري
اعتقد انهم لا يمكن السؤال لماذا صدر
القرار لا يمكن السؤال هل هناك سنه
القانوني لا يمكن السؤال
عندما يكون مبرر اصدار مثل هذا القانون
وكان قد تحدث قليلا عن ذلك دكتور نبيل
ميخائيل والسؤال لك دكتور نبيل اه عندما
يكون القلب المبرر كم امهات بان هذه
الجماعات ترتكب ربما اعمال العنف في هذه
الحاله المحاسبه على ارتكاب اعمال العنف
اليس المكان المناسب لها هو المحاكم وليس
انديه كره القدم
انا زي ما انا كنت بكم يعني مش راح النقاط
اللي ذكرها
تعطيني انا كنت عايز اقول حاجه مهمه جدا
ظهره ما عرفنا اش كلنا بنحب كره كلينا
مشاهدينا ينكره بس ما كوناش مثلا بيت بهذا
الحماس الدرجه يعني كانه حرب دي مسؤوليه
الانديه انت اللي داخل الاستاذ بتاع
النادي الاهلي بنادي الزمالك دي مسؤوليه
اه رئيس مجلس اداره النادي الاهلي نادي
الزمالك نادي المقاولين العرب نادي
الاسماعيلي
فالظاهر المفروض ما تخرج خارج استاد
الملعب خلاص انتهت
نهايه المباراه خلاص
اي انشطه
او غيره اه زي ما بقولك والمشاهدات الكرام
ومتابعه الكردي ظاهره غريبه على المصر على
على الشعب المصري على حتى بكره كل نسمه
عربيه الاخيره باتت مشجعه الزمالك رابطه
مشجعى الاسماعيلى فالامر مش مفروض يكون
سياسي انا اقول حاله بسيط جدا يعتبرها
منظمات اه من المحتمل انها تستعمل العنف
ولكن العنف موجود في الرياضه يعني
دكتورنا فكرتك واضحه لكن العنف الممارس في
الرياضه يفترض ان يكون مكان العقاب او
المحاسبه عليه هو المحكمه وليس ان كره
القدم
صحيح وبعدين كمان في الجانب المهني يعني
مثلا لو فيه نادي مشجعيه مثلا اه اساؤوا
معامله اه مشجعين نادي الاخر حتى ما فيه
عقوبات مثلا حرم حرم ان النادي من استضافه
مباريات في ارضه مثلا موضه كذا شهر ففيه
هناك الجانب الحرفي يعني في ال اتحاد
الكوره الكوره ما بيصير في قرار ما هي
ظاهره الالتراس اه كيف يمكن تنظمها مثلا
نص ساعه يصرحوا فيها الغايه تعبوا خلاص اه
لكن لدى تسييسها ولا داعي يعني الى انها
تخرج خارج الساحه الرياضيه هل يمكن
ايضا يعني يعني
يعني نحن نتحدث عن التداخل بين الرياضه
والسياسه لكن هل في الواقع يمكن تسييس
قرار مثل هذا الدكتور الدكتور نبيل اللي
تحدث عن الموضوع من زاويه شديده التقديم
شديده الجزئيه يتعامل مع الامر على انه
مجرد مشجعين الرياضيين يصرحون الامر اكبر
من هدف الكريم بكثير استاذ اثنين الامر
ونتحدث عن ظاهره اجتماعيه بدات تنتشر في
مصر في السنوات العشر الاخيره بد ان يكون
لها مزيد من الحد من المزيد من من التجييش
مزيد من الحج المزيد من التعبئه كانت
وسيله من وسائل التفريغ عن معدلات عاليه
من الكبت والضغط التي تمارس في ظل نظام
مبارك ثم في ظل انقلاب الانقلاب العسكري
وبالتالي الامر بعده السياسي القائم اي
ظاهره في ال ظاهره في العالم لها ابعاد
المتعدده السياسيه والاجتماعيه وغيرها
تحدث عن ان هذه اذا كانت هذه القضيه بهذه
الت بهذا الحجم هذا الحد من التقديم
والجزئيه ف هناك مؤسسات رياضيه تتولى مثل
هذا الامر وليس من شان اي مسؤول رياضي ان
يصنف اي جهه او اي جماعه او اي تنظيم
باعتباره تنظيما ارهابيا لان مثل هذه
التصنيفات بالاساس يجب ان يصدروا بها
قرارا من جهه فضائيه جهه قانونيه ان لم
تكن داخليه فبالاحرى ان تكون جهه اقليميه
او دوليه معنيه اذن هذا القرار او هذا
التصنيف بالتاكيد له تداعيات اه اه هذه
التداعيات المحتمله لتصنيف لجنه الانديه
روابط الالتراس ك جماعات ارهابيه
سنناقشها بعد الفاصل
ام
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش التداعيات المحتمله لقرار لجنه
انديه الدوري المصري بتصنيف روابط ال الك
راس جماعه ارهابيه نرحب بضيفنا من جديد
واليك دكتور نبيل ميخائيل في واشنطن الان
ما الذي يضمن انه يعني لا تصدر قرارات
مشابها ما وجهت هذه التحذيرات من امكانيه
ان تؤسس هذه الخطوه لفوضى اه اه تصنيفات
تهدد وامن وسلامه المجتمع المصري في
المستقبل
لو صدرت قرارات مشابهه طبعا حيبقى فيه نوع
من المقاومه ليها سواء عنفا او اه بطرق
غير عنيفه لكن اه في موضوع الاولتراس عشان
نلتزم ب سياق الحديث اه انا عاوز هم
التضارب في الملعب مشاعرهم يتظاهروا خارج
الملعب مش عاوز هم يستخدموا العنف اه لانه
ممكن ان تتحول يهم الى اه مواطنين
بيحاولوا اه يستخدموا العنف يعني هو اهم
من تقليهم جماعاتهم انه هو بيتحركوا
الكتائب في القوات المسلحه اعداد غفيره
بتتحرك وبعدين بتحاول ارباك الامن
وبالتالي احراقه وبالتالي ارغام اه قوات
الشرطه على تحقيق مطالبها اه
اساليب العنف بتاعتهم يجب التعامل معهم
بنفس هذه الاساليب طبعا بدون سقوط ضحايا
في موضوع تصنيف هم الارهابيين ممكن يوسع
القضيه اه ويؤدي الى مخاطر لانه ممكن فعلا
يحاولوا تنفيذ العنف افرادا او جماعات اه
خارج الملعب خارج نطاق المباراه اه في
ظاهره غريبه لكن من الافضل اه ان نتجنب
وصفها او نعتها ك اه ارهابيين لان يعني
اعدادهم كبيره وبعدين ما فيش مثلا فكر
الارهاب مش حنقول ان احنا ان يستولي مثلا
على نظام الحكم طبعا هما مشكله كبيره
مشكله المجتمع والمجتمع لازم من اقامه اي
شغب لكن يجب تصنيفهم على انها جامعات قد
تستخدم العنف محاوله اه مراقبته محاوله اه
يعني توضيح اه حماس منطقه الهائله التي
عبروا عليها في المال
اه بدون المهم يتحولوا اولى مشاغبين و
مشاغبين دائمين لان هناك يكون لهم خطوره
كبيره على الدوله
التداعيات نعم دكتور عصام امام برايك ما
التداعيات المحتمله او تبعات مثل هذا
التصنيف الان على امن وسلامه المجتمع
المصري خلينا نركز على
ان المكون الرئيسي لهذه الجماعات بالاساس
هو فئه الشباب التي تتراوح اعمارها بين
خمسطاشر عاما وخمسه وعشرين هذا رقم واحد
وبالتالي يمثلون هذا هو هؤلاء الشباب وهاي
تكون تمثل امل الامه في حاضرها ومستقبلها
لانهم هم عصب الثوره المصريه عصر النهضه
المصريه عصب الشيخ المستقبل المصري اذا
كنا نتحدث عن مستقبل هذا اول ما يجب
التاكيد عليه ايضا ان الاعلام والرياضه
كانوا احد اهم الادوات التي اعتبرت عليها
النظم السياسيه المتعاقبه في مصر كوسيله
من وسائل ال ال ها
شحنات الغضب والكبت التي تمارسها ضد
النظام السياسي ضد الشعوب ثالثا امر خطير
جدا جدا نحن في مصر ان نتعامل الان او
النظام السياسي القائم في مصر المقلب في
مصر الان يتعامل بالسياسه حافه الهويه اي
التصعيد في مواجهه كل التيارات السياسيه
ما لا يدركه النظام السياسي القائم في مصر
الان انه استمرار التشكك يمكن ان يدفع
كثير من التيارات السياسيه التي تمارس
الاعتدال الى استخدام العنف ردا على العنف
الذي يمارس ضد ها من جانب مختلف الاجهزه
حتى اصبحنا نتحدث عن عنف يمارس من جانب
الاجهزه الرياضيه ممثله في اللجنه الانديه
التي اصدرت مثل هذا القرار امر اخر مهم
اذا كان هناك النظام السياس القيم الان
يتحدث عن الامن القومي المصري فاعتقد ان
اهم السياسات التي يمكن بها حمايه الامن
القومي المصري هي الدفاع عن هي سياسه
الاحتواء بمعنى العالم على ال على احتواء
كل التيارات السياسيه كل التيارات كل
المجموعات والكيانات الشبابيه حتى
الرياضيه منها والفنيه والادبيه والثقافيه
وغيره ولكن ما يمارس غير ذلك وهو ما لا
يرى بالشكل مجالا للقول بان هذا النظام
ليس حريصا على امن الوطن ليست حريصه على
امن ابنائهم مستقبلهم ولكن كل حرصه على ان
يبقى مهيمنا متغلغلا مسيطرا على كل مقدرات
الدوله وكل مقاومتها ايا كانت التداعيات
التي يمكن ان تضغط على الدكتور نبيل
ميخائيل الان ما الذي يمنع اي مجموعه او
اه اه يعني فئويه نقابيه ما اخرى من ان اه
اه تجتمع وتطلق احكام ت ترتب عليها مواقف
قانونيه تجاه جماعه اخرى اذا ما مر اه هذا
التصنيف اللجنه انديه كره القدم ل اه
روابط الان تراس طبعا
تعتمد على درجه تاثيرها على المجتمع يعني
لنقابات العمال في اي دوله مصر او غيرها
اضراب طبعا راح يكون تاثيره اكثر عن
مشاغبات او حماس اه اه منظمه اه اه مشجعين
الرياضيين سواء اه عنفا يعني
في اضراب الموظفين
يعني مره يوم ان اذا منذ صدور هذا تصنيف
يعني
ما هو يعني الدوله
اه لكن اه مشهد عرضوا على القل لانه طبعا
من مصلحتها ان ي انها توقف عنف بس انا
برايي انهم جماعه ممكن يعني التحكم فيه
يعني مثل احدى مثالي جدا
كاس العالم مش حيكون مظهرهم بهذا الشكل
بهذا ال يعني الاسلوب العنيف فهما محتاج
نوع من المسؤوليه لا والحكومه تفاوت معاهم
واتهم خليكم على مسؤوليه شويه اه الامر
بكل التصنيفات خاصه بالارهابيين وغير
ارهابيين وبعدين اصل العرف لازم يحصل في
المباراه الكوري في الاحداث الرياضيه يعني
ممكن
شكرا دكتور اه دكتور عصام بالنسبه لي يعني
م مساله وجود مسؤولي اتحاد الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في اجتماع يتقرر فيه تصنيف مثل
هذا دلاله معينه برايك كما ذكرت حضرتك
هناك الان ما يمارس في مصر الان توزيع
الادوار بين الاسره الاساسيه التي يعتمد
عليها الانقلاب العسكري لتمرير او ترسيخ
سلطه من بين الادوات او الازمه التي يعتمد
عليها النظام العسكري الانديه الرياضيه
كما ذكرت ووسائل الاعلام وسائل الاعلام
معارضه قويه عدد محدود معده ومقدمه
البرامج الرياضيه يستخدمه كادوات من
لتمرير سياسات النظام اعتقد ان لدينا حدث
شيء الشهيره نحن انا وانت علينا منها على
خلفيه مباراه الجزائر الشهير بعض المعديه
معد البرنامج اداه من ادوات النظام اللي
تسعى الى التصعيد الى اقصى درجه ان نحنا
اصبحنا على وشك كان النفس في مواجهه حربيه
وليست في مواجهه رياضيه بين المصري اعتقد
الان وجود مندوبين عن جهاز الوزاره
التلفزيون او من قبل مندوبين عن وسائل
الامن المختلفه هو تاكيد للعلاقه الوثيقه
بين وسائل الاعلام ومؤخرا الانديه
الرياضيه التي اصبحت مجرد ادوات يستخدمها
النظام السياسي القائم في مصر الان لتثبيت
سيطرته
يمكن
اعتقد ابتداء يجب الرجوع عنه ثانيا لابد
ان تكون هناك حمله اعلاميه موسعه للتصالح
مع هؤلاء الشباب والعمل على احتواء هم
وتقنين اوضاعهم وان تكون محاسبتهم عن كل
الاخطاء وال وال خطا او الاخطاء او
الاعمال التي يمكن القيام بها منقوله
بالدرجه الاولى الى الجزيره الرياضيه وفقط
الاجهزه الرياضيه فقط باعتبارها شوطا
رياضيا داخل المؤسسات ال
يمكن باختصار شديد كيف يمكن ثلاثه اثار
مثل هذا القرار
جعلها قضيه رياضيه قضيه مسؤوليه الاتحاد
والحديث مع النادي ورئيس مجلس الاداره
بتاع النادي واقف ويتكلم رئيس رابطه
المشجعين
مش عارفين شاغره فى الشتيمه مفيش الفاظ
نابيه الامور ممكن يتحكم فيها حتى لو كانت
هناك يعني نوع من ال حماس الشديد والعنف
العنف يكون محكوم ويمتد خارج الملعب شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور نبيل ميخائيل الاستاذ
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج
واشنطن كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا ايضا
للدكتور عصام عبد الشافي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه شكرا لكما شكرا للمشاهدين ايضا
على حسن المتابعه لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
ام
نعم